Oh, I don't like that.
AAAAAAAHHH OKAY
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to "POPGOES".
Now, this is a Five Nights at Freddy's fan-game that came out about a half a year ago
Or maybe closer to a year now
I'm not entirely sure; but it did have about a year's worth of work put into it and after I just got done with
The Joy of Creation: Story Mode, now this one isn't free-roam as far as I know, in fact I know very little about this game
But I want to see these games that people
like, put their heart and sweat into. You know the
games that they really really slave over for-for very few rewards out of it
You know, they don't they don't charge any money for it
And I think that's very respectable about these-these indie games even if they are a derivative of something like Five Nights at Freddy's
The fact that people go out there
and they put so much work into it for nothing else than the love of the universe like that's
That's what I really want to see out of it. So I'm gonna give this a gander and
See what's going on here. I think it's more of classical Five Nights at Freddy's styling if I'm not too mistaken.
Oh...
Hi, oh oh, hi. You're near that's near that's—
I have a panic meter! I'm panicking right now! Why are you near?!
*Phone rings, recording begins*
*Grunts of exertion*
Fritz: Right, that should do it. *ahem*
Hey! Glad to see you're working there!
Mark: Yeah! That's me!
Fritz: The name's Fritz,
Fritz: And welcome to the Popgoes' Pizzeria.
M: Kay
F: The next generation of kids' entertainment.
M: Great!
F: As you already know, you'll be guarding this place until 6 in the morning,
and as your boss I'm obliged to help you understand your job and the tools you'll be allowed to use during your shift.
M: That's...uh...
F: So first things first,
F: I'm gonna be honest; your current setup might not be very... optimal, so to say...
I didn't have time to prepare a designated room in the location
so you'll just have to manage with using one of the internet cafe monitors near the stage,
next to the gang.
Don't start complaining just yet; I set a nice spot next to the window for you. Even brought a fan!
Anyway, the phone you have in your hand,
it's usually used by kids during the day for games and whatnot
but I've sorted out a security application that only activates during the night. Which is when you're here, obviously.
Everything you'll ever need for your job is ready to use. Go on, press some buttons!
You can check all the rooms with set cameras that are connected online, and the ventilation system too!
M: Great!
F: Alright, I know what you're thinking.
First night on the job, I'm rambling a bit, it's a lot to take in.
And yes, I know there are a bunch of anthropomorphic plastic animals around you, watching you work.
Trust me when I say I know how that feels. Your imagination might get a tad bit out of control. Stress does that to you.
But don't worry, you're completely safe here.
I've built this place from the ground up to be one of the most transparent, honest, and safest places on Earth. (Yeah sure)
Unlike... some other businesses.
M: Some!
F: If you ever start feeling anxious, looking out the window, or just... you know, taking a look outside,
should calm you.
That tends to work for me at least.
Right... Back to the anthropomorphic animals...
I'm sure you've already guessed by now that these are our animatronic characters.
M: Uh huh?
F: Top of the line technology.
F: Honestly the name animatronic doesn't do them justice. They're more like multi-purpose robots. They can be programmed to do anything
I can think of. They pretty much run this place now.
Of course, again they are completely harmless.
They aren't physically capable of hurting anybody.
*Loud Beeping*
F: Made sure of that myself.
Ugh, I think I might be going on for too long.
Last thing on the list. You may have noticed that this is a pre-recorded message,
which means if you want to ask a question, you won't get an answer.
But hey! To fix that I've given you some options.
I stayed up all night to set up a simple Q&A system to go with your app. When this call ends,
you will get three topics to choose from and when you select one of them another audio message of mine will play to help explain (Mark is panicking)
whatever you want to know more about.
Quite nifty, right?
M: NO!!!
F: Obviously not quite as much freedom as a normal phone call, but...
it will have to do for now.
M: A normal ph—
F: Well, that's it for your first night! Check those cameras and don't forget to take a breather once in a while, alright?
Your three options should appear... now.
M: Wait awughauwhg what is the room shut down button?
awuha What is this place during the day?
What is goi—W-why is there ten bajillion colors and buttons and dingdongs and flamdoodles??
WHY???
F: The Popgoes' Pizzeria!
Really is something, right?
M: *lets out a deep sigh full of pent up rage and past transgressions from Frtiz*
F: Which makes this a pretty broad topic to talk about,
F: but I bet you can just guess how most of it works by taking a look at the place.
M: OH THEN WHAT'S THE POINT OF THE CALLS THEN?
F: (Drowned out) Though I honestly think "the next
F: generation of kids' entertainment" sounds dull,
M: WHY?
F: it is a fitting motto.
F: When a kid opens the door, they can grab a WeaselWare Phone™ from one of the shelves
M: MMM
F: and play around with it.
F: The phone will connect to a monitor like yours, but during the day it'll let the kids
play games, make things with their 3D printers to paint on, use some of the re-purposed arcades, etc.
All of this and no staff required.
Yes, Popgoes and the crew keep the children and the equipment safe at all times.
If they see a kid gnawing on a phone or a wire, they'll just take it away from him, get their parents, sort it all out.
Of course, that's not everything, but, these options are meant to be short, so
i'll try to be more specific
M: PANIC!
F: in the other set of questions.
F: That's it for the first one.
M: OH!
F: See you tomorrow!
M: Hi!
Hello, where are you going? WHY AM I PANICKING?
WHAT'S THERE TO PANIC ABOUT?
THERE'S NOTHING GOING ON HERE; WHY IS THERE AN ARM THERE?
Oh! Let me look out the window! Ah. That's relaxing. I feel good about my life and my choices.
Good thing ol' WeaselWare™ got me on the weasel way to go wimbo wumbo out to Victory Land (Sarcasm)
Where the fuck is going on here?
What's happening? AND WHY?!
Why is th— anything happening?
Oh, that arms got me pic-panicked.
Oh, I don't understand any of this! There's so many buttons,
There's so many things to look at. Is someone there? Shut that down. How about this with the fan?
I don't know. I don't know what any of you is. Why is there a 3D printer in every room?
Look, that doesn't make any sense. Are you gonna print more animatromos on demand?
Is it completely self-sufficient like that?
Oh, what a nice window with a weird Chica looking thing in the... whatever that is.
Not my dog Chica. That's evil Chica.
Oh hi, okay, all right
Well, you just— diauhhh I don't know what to do about that, so I'm just gonna ignore it.
But what— what even?
what even do
Am I gonna die? HEY!
I heard something. I don't know what it was but I heard some'um!
Honk! Honk! Hink! Honk! hornk!
Ahh! Good window. Good. I don't think it's a window at all. Feels like a goddamn—
Oh! It is a window because that's relating to the ho, that's you!
Ahhh relaxing
If there's one thing that makes me think of, it's how relaxed I am
Ugh
Great
Yeesh
I think it's gonna be a relatively calm first night, but I have no idea what to expect out of this because nothing makes sense
God, if they went for like a more complicated routine on all this bullshit then boy howdy
did they do it. And I don't like the presents in there, that reminds me of the puppet
Gonna heat this vent up. I guess you know that's it's not so much heat that's kind of lasers
It's gonna slice them apart is that what you're gonna be doing about it? I don't know
oh my go- HEYYY
AIKJUHG-GOODBYE?!?! I guess? All right. Why'd you leave?
Where did you go?
*concerned screams of utter terror*
What are ya building there?
Ok see ya around the bend then all right toodle- toodles
toodles
Toodles Mr. Weasel cuz Pop goes that and you
Yugh, alrighty then
What am I supposed to take from this... so he didn't actually leave
You trying to- oh. Oh that's what he's doing. He's building something back there. I dunno what he's building, but I don't think it's good
So I don't know where he is- you above me?
So I don't know how anything can kill me. I don't know where it's coming from I don't know what I'm doing with my life
Why am I doing this why why why am I here what led to this point where this was my job where I'm surrounded by
a bunch of animatronics that aren't
Don't need any humans. So why would they need me to look over them? (Mark questioning life)
They'd probably just beat the shit out of anybody that tries to break in here-
WHO WOULD BREAK IN HERE!?
Why is there security in the first place?
That's like the best question! WHY? WHY would there be security in the first place in any of these *mumble* facilities?
IT DOESNT MAKE ANY SEEENSE!
If you think about it, who's gonna break in? THEY'RE GONNA DIE!
Who's gonna do it? NO ONE!
NO ONE is! WE'RE HERE TO KEEP THEM IN! WE'RE HERE TO BIDE THEIR TIME!
WE'RE HERE TO BIDE THEIR TIME!
I'M A VICTIM!
I'M BAIT!
Oh,
God...
Alright well 4 AM so either my imminent death is approaching me or I get to contemplate my own mortality a little LONGER-...
I don't like that! Well that's not good. I don't like the lights going flicky-flunky!
You want eeHOOWOOEY... How's it-okay! Okay! Alright! Hey! HEY! what's up buddy? How are you?
Oh, did I catch you at a-Oh, okay, alright then sorry about that. I didn't mean to catch you at a bad time
Whatever you say, you know, he's just holding that like "Yyeah, whutever, oohkay"
Jesus
All right
fuck
So what do I do? It's 5:00 a.m.. We're almost out of here. You back there?
Oh, there's another leg for some goddamn reason-ARE YOU JUST 'step in and out to build your little oh I DUNNO voodoo
doll of me and then... you can give me a nice back rub so I can feel good about myself... Maybe give it some pos-oohey, how's it goin-Hi-
Was that Bonnie?
Was that you-you-WHAT ARE YOU DOIN' TO BONNIE?!?!
HEY! WELL GETDAOOUU HEERRREE!
Okay-... I don't like that. (JUMPSCARE WARNING)
OOOKAY-
WELL!
WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO DO TO PREVENT THAT?!?
Now what could I have done?
I'm thinking nothing. The fuck? What was that? What happened?!
What happened? All right whatever  I'll go back in
Fuck, he was like some shadow Bonnie.
Why was there a shadow Bonnie? Why??
Okay, I think what- I think I understand what he was doing. He was going to these various 3D printers. Going in and out like
so that he could make the
pieces to get the Bonbon. Me staring at him didn't do a ding damn thing! Me staring at him
Did a whole lot of... Nothin'. Wait what was that? Oh, hi! Freddy? What are you doing here?
It shut down! Stop that you!
Whatever you're doing you're not even suppo-
Ohh he lied to you? Who lied to me? What're you talkin about?! Im PANICKING! UAAAHHH-
Oh no, ok-Ah, nice window, ah, good, relaxing,
Feels so good
Alright so- Ah there you are. Hey. NO, how many times I gotta shut down that goddamn room!? How about you bennnOOOOoo...
Put some heat on that room. UH, put some HEEEAT on that
Alright yeah. Ohh what you got thwarted? OH bitch! Oh, no. Oh, you dad, not you 'dad' you dead
(weird inhale)
A-shu-guh-yu-gu-whu-ah-yu-yu-yu-
"We think. We care." Well shut up! Who did that? Im panicking here- I'm so PWANICKED-
WaaAAaa!
Whoa. What the fuck was that? Do you guys hear something? (Nope)
I heard something...
Whoa wha what- Hey! No, not in the birthday room. You don't go me-makin a new birthday party. What was that?
Was that just a combination of noises that I already heard or was that something else?
Hi, I see you in there! Where you going? You go in the art room? Oh?
Well, that's a mistake because I got my eye on you. Oh, don't even think about that
I don't know what these colors do but Noooo...  Where'd you go, huh? Which way you ooH
nO
No-no you're not getting it this time-
I got my eye on you, and I know exactly what you do even though now
Im serious and I don't have as much time as I had before because I'm
ffssfs this is....
fuckin stupid...
Goddammnit 3-D printers...
Oh, I see you-oh, where'd you go?
Where'd you go, buddy? Huh?
Whoa- NO!
Alright, so this seems easy
Now I just got to relieve my stress by looking out this pitch-black
window where anybody could be literally staring into me. 'Cause if it's bright in here that means it's... everyone could see me
Pretty much, right?
Alrighty then..
Oh wait wha- No! Not the vent! Not the vent!! Not the vent!! Not the vent!! Ugh, there we go..
Okey okey okay...oooh...
Birthday room huh? Where's that?
Oh I see it
Oh, you didn't actually go there. Oh there he is! Go away
So not so bad, so just a whole lot of this, right? That's it?
I can deal with this. I can do this. This is easy. I got this
Doh, "We will kill you". Why will you kill you- me? Why would you do that? I don't want a kill- uh no!
Let me look out the window. Oh sure was startling
"Calm down-" Who are you?! What ice princess- we got Frozen over here?  We don't need any of that!
Who are you?!
Who the hell were you? Why were you in ice? Why were you ice!? I don't even remember what you said
'Kay.. 3 a.m... Doing alright! Not too shabby! Not too bad...
Not too bad...
M'kay, we're at 5 a.m.
which means that we should be getting through this because I think
If I'm not mistaken this thing is- this game is gonna introduce like one concept at a time
So when it comes to these colored buttons. I don't know what they do with the big button over here
I don't know what that does... hEEuhy..
What was that? That was a new sound
Or is that the same sound with me screaming like a little bitch over it because I can never tell the difference? (Both likely)
Also, what the hell's going on with above me? Like what am I gonna
do if something is above me? Like how am I gonna stop that? I don't exactly have a way to stop that unless it's that
button on the.. side there.. nO
Don't do that!
According to the colors of the rainbow: FAHCK OFF!
Boinky boinky oinky!
Pop goes the FUCK you!  All right where the heckie-  I'm not gonna panic, sir
Don't tell me what to do you being out there and somehow in here at the same time
I don't like that. But it's got to be over pretty soon
It just has a different- yeah, I can't tell is that a pig? Or is that a weasel?
Is that what a weasel looks like in animatromo form? I don't know, but I'm almost done
Just gotta hold on for a little longer!
Also, why were they making shadow Bonnie? Like that's a completely other story!
And why would I need to go look outside? Like I could look outside right here
It's not like that caused me to panic any less. I got this asshole staring at me right in the face...
Oh no you dont! I haven't let you get a single piece of that shadow Bonnie bullshit, not about to start now!
Oh you ladies up there gonna help out or not, huh? Yeah, that's right. Stay there. Go away. Hate you.
All right
Doink doink doink doink doink
Come on! Stooiii- There we go!
(8-bit style Pop Goes the Weasel starts playing)
Whoo!
Okay, well, we got that. So that's good
O-Well
Oo what's happening here?
Oh!
Well, am I in someone's stomach?! What is this?
EEEEEEWWW!
Ew, don't like that.. oh and what am I?
wha-g-cuh-
What am I? Some kind of, like Dark Chica? Is this Chicas dark name?
Ugh.
Dark persona... maybe?
Where we going? Oh, y-you were crystallized! Or frozen? Or or or or or-
something! I don't fully understand what
Oh good! Balloons!
Great.. Where the hell am I going? Why the hell am I going there? And what is happening to me?
I don't know... I don't think I want to know..
Balloon?!
Balloon Boy nOOO
Balloon Boy's been murdered? Question mark?
Depending on where we are and why we're here
Is this what the inside of an animatronic's brain looks like?
Probably..
Oi..
Oh no! Is that Balloon Boy's clothes?
He's naked somewhere. Oh, NOOOOOO
Oh! The humani-
Oh, hi Bal-
OH
'Kay..
Balloon Boy!
That was your hat. I just realized that was your hat not your clothes
Well, I mean, your hat's part of your clothes, but whatever. Alright then, second night. What are you gonna tell me?
Also, I'm gonna die and skip this because d-I or.. whatever. Alright, what do you got for me? Heat vent to stop noise?
WHY?
Who left this sticky note?
Who did that?
who did thattt?
Oh he's gone already? Okay, I'll see ya, toodles then. Or whatever..
OH JUST PICK UP THE GODDAMN PHONE!
F: Right, hey again. Second night.
M: Yes.
F: Have you gotten used to your job by now?
M: nOOO
F: - it's all on a phone. You'll have trouble finding a job that actually requires you to be on one of those.
Anyway, I expect efficient use of that phone, yep.
Oh and I'll let you know now; don't start slacking off on paying attention.
After your first week is done I'll be doing a review of your program to see if you are fit to continue or not. (M: Oh! Hi. Hello.)
If you do your job especially well, I might even give you a bonus.
M: OOOHH!
F: Though I guess there isn't even very much for you to do
I know I haven't given you much to work with just yet. This is just the test run.
But there is something for you to do in case you-
M: "His name is Fritz"?
F: -since. Well, Im not going to treat you like those robots behind you.
So, we're entering the winter time. I imagine you'll be working just next week so it's going to get pretty darn cold for you.
But- and I'm sure you've already noticed this from yesterday; I dont know.
PPFFF
F: I have given you access to the ventilation system.
Which means you should be able to- M: Oh shit did he get one?
F: heat it once in a while to warm up yourself. M: Oh he did.. fuck
F: They stay on for about a minute, probably, but that'll be long enough, right?
Bear in mind the vents go around the perimeter of the building so that.. oh I'm sure you'll figure it out.
Well that should keep you entertained.
Don't want to hurt when you're as easily pleased as I am.
That's all for tonight.
Oh, wait, no. If you want a turn to talk, here you go. Ah yes as I said,
M:  Wha-da- I didn't know I was picking something! And then you just picked it for me, you asshole!!
I DONNO WHAT YOU- aw okay you're gone. Oh, you. No. No!
F: -this time and I can't risk that-
M: Jesus..
F: We all know what happened to that.. attraction last year. I- (sigh)
I remember I worked with a similar problem.
You know, being under constraints like that. But-
I dunno. It was fine. I was fine and I'm sure you will be too.
Nothing dangerous about vents.. (clears throat)
What am I saying? Just check on the heat sometimes and yes, you'll have limited use over it.
And I'm sorry about that.
Right
I'll see you tomorrow.
M: WHO LIED TO ME!?
Who did?! Who are you talking about?! I don't know what you doing!
Ughhhh
Wa-tch bowl of candy, fuck..
"We will kill you" Great. Okay. Where is he? STOP BLOCKING MY GODDAMN VIEW!
You fucking ASSHOLES!
Oh great.
Oh, I'm panicked.
Uh oh.
weLP
I think I'm dea- HEYYY!
Connection lost, eh? Alright, well
well..
Okay, well, anyway that is Popgoes
I'm probably gonna try to get at least through like the five main nights
If that is what it is, because this isn't called Five Nights At Popgoes
This is called Popgoes! So we're gonna see what this game is all about later on.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down in the comments below
And as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh- Bye!